I don't really like to do it McGregor I
don't like to do because I called my
prostitute let's go back I'm a quorum a
lot of things on everything I'm gonna
call him now be nice down to the tone I
gotta be me you know you got me in here
I gotta be me
Conner have five plus right he quit and
oh five back [ __ ] well welcome
everybody to another edition of hot
boxing with Mike Tyson I'm Evan Britton
and I'm Mike Tyson Mike we got a we got
a great guest today have too much fun
we've got ali abdel aziz correct is your
name correctly said perfectly awesome
menu among other things your kebabs
manager your Fabrizio's manager yes
you're a good buddy cody gar Brant as
well correct yes and we're excited to
have you here man it's a it's such a
huge honor of a cuisine but when one
drop one drop call me he said you know
like I met Mike Mike a couple of times
and was was Habib and was robbing stuff
for that and I never been a like a
fanboy like you know a celebrity like
like movie stars
but grown up I idolized Mike you know
III idolized my grown up in Egypt
you know Mike Tyson was the biggest
thing grown up and and on first time I
see Mike I kinda I'm like a groupie but
I want to hold it together you know but
I I met so many famous people I really
don't don't care you know III just
that's not who I am you know and I see
Mike my hand started swaying and after
that weren't his house one day was
khabib and I was like man I don't want
to go in and have you said no just come
in come in and after that we went in and
since then might be amazing he's
somebody I looked up to for a long like
you doing a lot of stuff in there too
you know yes yes yes um start starting
to shine to know what you're doing so
let's talk a little bit about that and
you know 2018 been crazy for me you know
you got this you know some guys fought
war titles you know one and you got this
crazy McGregor can be fight I'm sure you
guys want to talk about that hey we're
all ears brother you know you can ask me
what sort of fight what do you think no
one [ __ ] tapped out and what did you
do man
yeah listen you know if could we can we
rewind it a little bit though how did we
get to that you know yeah could be you
know I don't really like this dude
McGregor I don't like to do because I
record my prostitute let's go back I'm a
quorum a lot of things and everything
I'm gonna call him now be nice don't do
the tone listen I gotta be me you know
he got me in here I gotta be me do you
let's go back you know let's be real
it's a reason why they in a white the
greatest promoter if in any sports in
any athlete because without the in a
white and Connor that combination would
not be here because I think Connor
McGregor is manufacturing UFC
manufacturers he got the way he is not
because he was the greatest fighters or
double champs tougher that they know why
I put him in a position to be there you
know he felt a whole bunch of you know
guys can he never fought a wrestler
right the only wrestler he fought would
chef Manders and to two week notice when
he was hunting for four days right and
he was losing this fight like I think
the UFC no they have something very
special a guys ready he can talk [ __ ]
yeah
in we can promote and they said okay we
got our golden goose let's give him the
easiest pass right listen
anything can happen a fight one punch
right that's why he knocked out although
but nine thousand naka nine but it is
but the whole thing is he really been
although before the fight he abused him
and you know the UFC was in on it
although team allowed it and this why
with us we know we stayed calm and
collected
you understand and you know Connor
should have fought kabhi let me tell you
a story right first time in Madison
Square Garden the UFC was supposed to
happen
we had about agreement between 80
Alvarez and khabib right but the UFC
really wanted Conor McGregor to fight 80
Alvarez and they used khabib tentative
Conor you know what [ __ ] you if you
don't fight we're gonna let Conor fiber
at the same time they told 80 if you
don't agree to deal they're very much
kabhi was the boogeyman you understand
he's the number one contender and I got
both guys to agree on a deal to show
khabib Hey you can fight khabib and [ __ ]
him and said you know khabib didn't get
the shot and they they made a business
decision I'm okay with it today because
if I was in my spot I'm gonna make two
hundred million or I'm gonna make fifty
million I'm gonna I'm gonna go with
Connors two hundred I'm just you know
listen I rendered a a lot of people said
now people said I work for the UFC I
work because normally or I work for
Bellator I work for BFL normally a
management promoter shortly they have
beef I don't have beef with no managers
right it was it was any promoters
because by having beef was promoters it
can affect my fighters and I will keep
it a hundred percent with it anyway
we'll go back to this Irish prostitute
story right all right
and after that you know happy you know I
heard again here this back and he have
to kind of pull out was Tony Ferguson
and and stuff happen anyway
they said okay Habib now's the champ I
supposed to fight twenty Ferguson
Brooklyn twenty person got hurt he
fought a la quinta whooped him fifty
twelve forty you know forty three
whatever anyway the second is next right
but what happened is the fight night
wouldn't when when Habib's was too far a
la quinta one of Connor's teammate was
there his name is artem Lobo and this is
the first time somebody gonna break down
the story right
honest to god the truth anything what
happened and this died artem you know
he's the only reason he's an EFC because
Connor is he's a bump in
but you know when you're a champion
scientist guy and uh and he's very much
got any of Sheba's Connor you know and
he started doing interviews in Russia
and and say hobby was a [ __ ] javi
please Habib this and well his name is
Artem you know or he's no longer with
the UFC he's out right huh
but he started talking [ __ ] he started
talking [ __ ] about khabib in the Russian
media because he's Russian right but in
a way a certain type of the word like a
film from Brooklyn you can't call the
other man a [ __ ] right and where I'm
from again if you if you feel in prison
you can't call other man a [ __ ] and I'm
saying it's a fight word and anyway and
different culture in a Muslim culture or
you know different countries you can't
call it a man a [ __ ] but you know kabhi
kabhi business cuz it's nice kid he's
also quiet smile suffer then but
realistically cabbie was from Dagestan
you know I'm saying dog is ten is a
place it's a war zone you know I'm
saying the gun wants to Olympic champion
and wrestling and it's it is a high
style place it's respect is number one
everything else is number two a lot of
places is money number one respect in
Dagestan and Chechnya place she went to
respect is number one yeah and you came
for you let us appear you banished
you've any way any way you know but but
that show you how real this is yeah
khabib saw him don't file week until he
went to him and I was cubby he rolled up
on him and he have a friend with him
the cabbie was a nice kid you know you
never secret talk [ __ ] about nobody it's
funny guy you know and he went to him
and he he grabbed him is yo why why I
never knew you and why do you call me
that and he's like oh you know these I
never said that I said yo he said but
all to be wanted to say I said it I'm
sorry
he's a forgiving guy man you know hey
you know and then he started denying it
and I have used again I'm hungry and he
got like you got like 20 do deal with
him and I say yo everybody needs to back
off
let him talk with this man
right and after that Kabhi was talking
and he started denying it denying it and
I was like yo she's [ __ ] admit it and
apologize and after that khabib like you
know Lu give him the little little
bridge Samsung there was slapping and
slaps just back at them back at the head
and after that I stepped in and one of
his friend with him he started on his
mouth and after that one of the guy you
know just cracked him but I took Artem
because I know he's fighting and I think
he's fighting let him do his thing
listen if the other man grabbed my head
like that the first thing I'm gonna do
I'm gonna take off on him I'm not gonna
let nobody touch me and I'm 41 years old
I don't care who is if somebody grabbed
my head like there and talked about that
I really know he's soft
and I thought happy baby soft
[ __ ] but all but all these guys
talking like they they they they can
they can blow smoke a lot of people come
blow smoke but the question is can he
inhale the smoke and I know he's a [ __ ]
and just let him go
I took him and the video show under my
wing sale get outta here stop leave
whatever we done we're going for the
media day right and we did the media day
everything is okay and we are not bus
you know you know the bus instead in
Brooklyn yeah Park Lisa Anna and we
didn't a bus you know finish the media
going to make weight and we saw a lot of
people boom boom boom we thought was
like fan you know and after that like
got like crazy and it was a lot of girls
in the bus Habib me whatever and uh and
after that like we saw we know something
right and we saw Connor throw a dolly
through the bus yeah
the corner through the dolly through the
BA doli were your thing you will stuff
around like like a big thing yeah and if
you go back to the video it was me a
little of TV and it was me and cubby two
teammates right Anna when they hit the
bus was roll your Rozier Eunice I'm
I could guess it there and they cut
michael Chiesa right it was bleeding the
first thing I wanted to do I want to
jump out of the bus and Kathy was
sitting smiling he said and I was I was
so angry because I felt like we get
ambushed by like 2030 guys and I I want
to jump our bus but a little TV grab
means he's a light heavyweight he
grabbed me and I really wanted to get
out of bus because I don't know man I I
don't like to be in a box and people try
to kill you you understand unhappy I
said hey relax I said if somebody if
gangster come they don't bring video
cameras because when Connor come he
brought all his cronies low dude but
they have video camera throw but he said
real gangster don't bring with you pants
stone-cold man yo he was sitting he
didn't get up ha beep was smiling when
all the stuff was gone he didn't get up
and after that this stuff could happen
this guy's happened they laugh you know
they brought the video camera they saw
jumping around anyway this whole thing
went on you know Dana come says sorry
all that and you got all this woman it
was a two man crying tearin' hide it
under the bus some of the UFC employee
like it was high like like skip like it
was like it's insane it's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know if you have beef with somebody
like I will say hey send me a message
say me location we can do one-on-one he
can go under the Brooklyn Bridge 8 on 18
19 20 and 20 we can get it is no problem
but you don't put other harm other
people and and you know and I we
understand at the time I didn't really
know Connor but we understand corner
he's a [ __ ] because only [ __ ] can do
this you understand if you have beef
with a man she walk up and and you know
take off her name or whatever but to
understand the man he want to promote
himself he want to be on TV but he
didn't understand he you know Irish is
different rules right this is New York
City the NYPD will get you punk ass you
know and that's what happened he went to
jail you know he paid some money come
out you know it was a great promotion
for the UFC you know but
realistically khabib of course he wanted
to make money and he made he made a lot
of money in his fight but it was
personal
right it would become a personal it will
become a couch surfers culture it become
right versus wrong who come evil versus
good you know I'm saying it's it's
people said Ali and Frazier was big I
think the story behind this that of
course this is gonna be the biggest
right or Lou and Lenny close but I think
this one you know it got so much Iran
like yeah some of the best pre-fight pre
antic was Mike Tyson Lennox Lewis
listen hey me or Rashad Evans used to
stay in the dorms at Greg Jackson's and
for for a year and every day we had a
DVD player and we watch Mike Mike his
documentaries Rashad I think one of the
biggest fan and after the documentary
was finished Rashad he starts imitating
you right and even at one point he tried
to boxer like you
I'm not joking Rashad I think roshanda
and and that's how I got introduced you
but like like the Mike Tyson I know Mike
Tyson growing up but the real Mike Tyson
you know my talk about that pre-fight
that those pre-fight antics yeah I want
to listen to it and then the fights and
the [ __ ] talkin and what's going through
your head I don't know I don't remember
this tomorrow I do my mom in my sick
head I was the baddest man in the room
nobody better talk to me nobody better
look in my face you know it's just it
was just that way I mean yeah I guess
they believe that crap you know I mean
because it's just that's just how I felt
that that I wanted to fight it can't
wait to do it yeah so you're ready to
rock every second outside the ring all
the time ready to fight them that hair
trigger it's ready yeah all the time
because I mean watching those press
conferences it's like it's like Conor
it's just a non-stop shit's shit-talking
lateral doing nerves you know the yes
yeah let me let me tell you something
about Connor right he's a he's a guy
he's is manufactured by the UFC but you
know the whole thing is
a lot of [ __ ] believed the hype
and he thought the hype was real
we know all along he's a [ __ ]
we know all along you understand i'ma
tell you what these guys who is all
about right
he guy he's he come from something no
nothing right but a lot of people in
this game Mike will tell you about that
right they never forget where they come
from they never think that are bigger
than the game right
he thought he's bigger than the game and
all the time my slogan social media I
said respect the game because if you
don't respect the game the game would
take away eat you alive you understand
and this is a guy he got used to the
same kind of attention by the way he
talked and and he he disrespected every
opponent when Mike [ __ ] was his opponent
clinic Luis and he said I'll [ __ ] you -
you love me thank you you know all that
yeah I'm saying that was your [ __ ]
real yeah because that was we fighting
you understand he never talked about the
man and religion culture race corner
crossed all that yeah he called people
[ __ ] midgets you know I'm saying like
you know maybe probably he was never
hugged as a kid maybe he wasn't here
this is maybe he wasn't getting laid
you know I'm saying when he was a kid
maybe you know I'm saying but Fame and
money change people that's why I told my
guys that was Chuck I never got laid to
the kid girls didn't like me the kids
later the kid like his agent is an
unsecure uncomfortable man his own skin
right you understand you understand and
he and guess what he comes to America a
culture they don't see they don't see
these guys you can't compare like one of
the things I love being a wife one of
the things I was so mad he compared my
corner to Muhammad Ali how the [ __ ] he
gonna do that
I was angry about this when I wrote that
much well you can't do that stuff you
don't mean Muhammad Ali was not a [ __ ]
maja no way Muhammad Ali was a real
[ __ ] robot I do today
Connor have five pluses right he quit
and oh five fights he didn't get beat he
quit he gave up he quit and this is who
is he quit like IRA in the day when you
the hammer everything is [ __ ] is good
but he when you the nail sometimes it's
hard to make decisions you know and uh
yeah and and that's why that's why I
called my prostitute I'm not saying he
getting he's getting screwed for money
you know I don't know you know but I
think a heap a promote himself as a
prostitute but he's oppressed is a high
end prostitute because he have money
have fame but he still want to get this
attention right you know he's not all an
act
I mean listen our end the day I think
does he go he goes goes beyond yeah i'ma
tell you something these do said about
me
he said I was caught in an after the
nine one one was five paid fake passport
he said how this man inside this country
I was caught was five fake passport in
turn the country's and he's a [ __ ] no
listen and he said I was a terrorist you
know I'm saying listen I'm not a true
[ __ ] no I'm not I'm not perfect you know
I did I did wrong things in life you
understand but it's for me to know but
I'm not no [ __ ] terrorist I didn't
get caught was passport you know I'm
saying but a tender day this be real you
know I'm a young African man was Muslim
descent I'm the youngest manager in the
game successful listen you got all these
lawyers and roasted guys stuff are there
nobody you know I manage 125 I got
eighty percent I got eighty fighters and
you see the second-biggest manager got
twenty I understand a lot of
[ __ ] don't like me people want
to you know their bro you got me but but
but but but the whole thing is is very
simple
I'm a guy ice-t trained five days a week
you know why do you do it weights no I
don't live tweet III spar two times a
week I grapple I wrestle the whole thing
is a love martial arts
yeah this is but also it keep me I
understand what fighters go through I
understand I thought too but I wasn't on
the level day on on no I wasn't a good
fighter I wasn't well I think that's
really cool man that you come you have a
background as a fighter so you know what
these guys need and what they're going
through and I know you're not gonna put
a guy in his third fight in Japan
against the dude mozilla 3030 and for
now like you would never do and this why
like you know this whole you know we'll
go back to the press conference you know
and start calling as terrorists and this
and this and this
and it was it was a I don't really enjoy
it I didn't like it but the person kept
all calm khabib have you said everything
is good everything is great i'ma handle
this and he went there calm and cool and
collective you understand they know why
to saying corners the big box when you
see right big right he got dropped was
an overhand right by hobby and hobby was
a wrestler right and that's why I go
back Connor I'm not saying he's a bad
fighter he's a he's a he's a good
fighter Mike Tyson was a great fight
right
we talked recently through social media
right I don't want to mention what we
said and I British months I told him he
got some issues did you call him a
prostitute yeah I know you have some
problem going on right now and I very
much I said hey I say [ __ ] ass
[ __ ]
the difference between me you and us we
don't talk about family you don't talk
about your religion about this whatever
you do the best of luck and start
working arrest them cuz your wrestling
is a [ __ ] bum bum ass [ __ ] I said he
respond some crazy [ __ ] but you know
it's good me I'm Floyd been talking to
each other - yes yeah I mean I got
listen to me if [ __ ] Floyd said
he doesn't talk with me I got text and
I'ma put on plans ain't ya yeah you know
because after the
fight Floyd reach out to me Ida reach
out to him he called me and he said
listen you know I want to fight khabib
and I want to change you guys his life
claw blah blah and I pretty much said
how are you gonna change our life you
know because and he's like I know we
start after that we talk we start
texting right and we've been texting for
almost four months I talked to this guy
you know what's his name
yeah but he's nothing he's [ __ ] zero
I think Lana's the [ __ ] just just you
know there to talk I don't know I know
how to talk you know I'm saying he's
he's if he's a promoter he's the worst
[ __ ] promoter he can ever say I
think Floyd one of the greatest promoter
of all the time see Floyd is a real deal
because he can talk and he can fight
corner is not con reason is that he's a
Chinese version of Floyd Mayweather
[ __ ] bootleg you can buy this
[ __ ] on Canal Street in New York
you know or go to Brooklyn and bed-stuy
get some of them them African stores the
oldest knock out she might know what I'm
talking about yeah I used to sell those
yeah but you know this corner thing man
you know not now Corner want to fight
everybody want to fight this guy what a
fancy for a rematch listen to me he do
want rematch he said the u.s. you have
to protect the investment right if
corner and I think that you have see is
wrong right now because if corner [ __ ]
Aviv now the same result is gonna happen
maybe it's gonna get worse right but
it's such a huge money fight because
they they can promote the Brooklyn thing
and they can promote what happened in
Las Vegas right you know be jumping over
the kitchen all that yeah but now
they're probably gonna match him with
somebody else but he's gonna lose and I
told this today and I said yo cash out
because this [ __ ] doesn't train
he got too much money you know and I
want think to the US people blame the
UFC promoting the despite promoting the
bus they have to promote yeah what are
they have to promote how are you gonna
blame him and Nevada saying oh we
have to control the trash-talking
leading up to the fight this is this is
the fun of the fight is the greatest
thing the fan look up to to promote a
fight you look up my classes fight the
fight they [ __ ] last [ __ ] 30
seconds but realistically realistically
you watch it the bill tops man I used to
wait manorama's young kids waiting [ __ ]
man these interviews and and and and
just wait just to want to listen you
know and this is what really make combat
sport is the greatest thing ever because
I think fighting it's in our DNA if you
go to a basketball game right in the NBA
final and a fight broke understand
what's gonna happen you gotta turn
people around or what your fight I think
human being is an international foreign
language it's an international language
people light fights you understand you
know interesting it's just people like
to fight men and and I like to watch you
fight even people doesn't like to fight
people would love to watch a fight
people helping here that's what since
the beginning of time this is kind of
what happened with Carter man Conor the
one does free match and his team that
won this rematch the UFC the one this
rematch because UFC always want to make
money but they understand if Connor lose
again his value go down very very bad
and listen he didn't lose he got him
elated you understand he guy talk all
this kind of stuff even more so talking
all the [ __ ] yes you know and then
getting your ass kicked for did he say
some about you my Conor he's talking
[ __ ] I think he likes Mike he said some
[ __ ] that he says been my money wife
said about yeah don't thing is like it's
crazy because what happened if him and
my got locked in the same room same what
happened guarantee you carnal be in the
[ __ ] corner a might I'm sorry a ma'am
sorry please forgive me you know listen
probably Connor by self I think maybe
he's a very nice guy but you got so many
mother [ __ ] around they yo you the man
you diss you do this all right fellas
Norman
you happy my kids yeah what you like
doing with them which what have we done
with you
I love my you know what I love you took
them back to Egypt my wife went back to
Egypt you know my kids have not went
back to Egypt yet
yeah man [ __ ] me if you go too easy man
I you're probably gonna have you know a
long thing like my wife and my kids go
listen if you go to his house mahal had
a ball you went to Egypt Taj Mahal in
India man I think each if you're gonna
love easy pan and Mike Mike that's in
Egypt he's bigger he's bigger than the
present I believe you are bigger than
the ball give me the barricade no he
will have a barricade I will set him up
he will have a barricade you understand
man like like Mike has become like an
international trademark brand for life
yeah you understand that's why they
doing this Tyson ranch
talking about this thing yeah oh you
know about that some lunch
title matches is the biggest thing you
know and you have the Mike Tyson brand
behind and a Mike inhale it breathe it
live it smoke it blow you know something
is something is something organic you
know yeah but you know I don't smoke
weed but a lot of my fighters smoke weed
see a lot of the things my fighters
defend them over here I say ninety I
manage on 120 fighters right 80% of my
roster smoke weed current world champion
they smoke weed and I said yeah why yes
my believer they said man they make the
inflammation down yeah it's better than
drinking it make me relax and if I smoke
I'm held up and they use the coppers
real stuff Rob given and that CBD oil
and how's that knowledge no I'm sure if
I have to choice or smoke I said of
course like you know you'd much rather
smoke look was listen medically
you know they said smoke I don't smoke
and I'm saying you know I'm never gonna
smoke roughly but that ended they this
fighters telling me this and I'm talking
about guys defending titles work class
and listen it's crazy
one of the best condition I think maybe
I'm
I'm not gonna measure his name it's my
[ __ ] smoke [ __ ] a lot of weed
every time I'm around
yo how you fight I love that high five
wrong and he says [ __ ] me yeah I feel
like I smoke weed yeah better yeah
another and I don't know much about it I
never been high I feel like I'm being
high of contact now I might hit it but
it's a but you know I'm not smoking but
you know what honest me work makes me
happy to my kids make me happy my wife
this is and I know sometime I'm a lot
I'm gonna lie I'm always my kids is my
life you know my kids is my life and so
I'm so grateful to have my kids and they
healthy I don't care about money this
this my kids healthy this is very
important and I love my fighters man you
know you know my fighters win I'm happy
my father's happy it's crazy when I have
all my fighters in town I bring
everybody to my house twenty thirty guys
and my wife make dinners and my father
and Micky Bob and I have to invite you
one time I think I'm bad I know it's
awesome dude I'm not especially high in
this [ __ ] on you are I've seen
I'm seeing W my good product man good
product not for sure man it's such an
honor to be with you guys yeah Thank You
Man for sure Mike you want to take us
out yeah this is another great episode
on hot boxing I'm Mike Tyson I'm Evan
Britain this is ali abdel aziz what an
amazing time and what are the highlights
of my career being better for you guys
oh yeah thank you love you until next
time everybody
peace we out
[Music]